the story I meant to get to this a few
days ago glad I got to it now it's kind
of grizzly
and really really stupid
story here it is on daily wire man
Googled how to dispose of 115 pound
woman's body now his 115 pound wife is
missing
this is you almost want to laugh at the
headline except you realize someone's
been killed you know someone some guy
murdered his wife here it would seem and
and it's a guy from Massachusetts
who looked up how to dispose of this
particular kind of body and then his his
wife was supposed to take a ride share
to the airport in Boston for New Year's
Day there's no record she took the ride
share she never boarded the plane and
then she was reported missing by her
workplace and her husband and then when
law enforcement searched the guy's
computer it says how do you how do you
dispose of a 115 pound woman's body not
really sad story not the brightest
criminal in the world it would seem I
guess he's innocent until proven guilty
but not looking good
not looking good for the husband
the reason I bring up the story is not
because it's of this local crime story
Odd as it is but it's because of what it
tells us about one of the biggest issues
in our politics which is the
surveillance State we are increasingly
living in a surveillance State and that
has been increasing for decades now it's
been increasing in the government sphere
you think of the NSA formerly known as
no such agency which is just processing
countless reams of all of our data
constantly but then you think of it in
the private sphere as well you think of
private companies that now have access
to what we search on the internet
private companies that have access to
who we call Private companies that have
access to cameras inside of our homes
it's just it's just everywhere now on
our TVs our TVs very often have cameras
our cars are spying on us to
corporations
so we're living in this this total
surveillance State and our first
reaction to that is that this is very
bad and it is bad because it's giving
bad people undue power
it's get it's giving frequently Very Bad
actors leverage over us and control over
our lives
there is a silver lining though you know
on this show I try to have a little
silver lining I don't really get angry
and pull my hair out and say the world
is ending all that much I I try to look
for the Hope here because I think that's
a a theological fact and a requirement
of our lives so here's the silver lining
the surveillance state
can keep you on the straight and narrow
it can people don't want to hear it but
it's true
if you knew I mean this is how a lot of
those
anti-porn apps work I think it was Matt
fradd really great podcaster was talking
about this that you get if you want to
quit porn if you have an addiction to
porn you get some of these apps and
services that basically whenever you
look at a porn website it just emails
whoever you tell it to email so it can
be a buddy it could be your wife it
could be you know and and so it's a it's
a voluntary kind of surveillance but if
you know voluntary or not if you know
that every single thing that you type
into your computer is going to be seen
by somebody else
you're probably not going to go to that
naughty website that you want to go to
now you you might if you're living in
China saying you know all your searches
are going to be seen by the government
you're also probably not going to Google
things like democracy or how to lead a
political revolution or things like that
but but even just in our personal lives
if we know that somebody is watching
we're probably going to be a little
better behaved
if you see a camera in a store you're
probably going to be a little loath to
rob that store unless you're in San
Francisco where it's just a complete
free-for-all if you are in in your home
even or in your workplace
surveillance can make you behave a
little bit better
the reason that this is happening now
is one there's been the technological
advances in surveillance but there's a
cultural reason to and it gets back to
one of these statements that John Adams
said in the early days of our country he
said a statement frequently quoted by
conservatives that the country is built
for a moral and religious people it's
not fit for the government of any other
kind of people that the American
expression of political Liberty and
relative privacy
is built for people who are going to
control themselves and rein in their
basist passions
the country is built for people who
believe that God is watching them at all
times and they better not step too far
out of line
as that belief has declined in the
United States
you you have seen an increase in other
kinds of surveillance
police surveillance in private
surveillance in surveillance by your
teachers and your professors and your
bosses and everybody else
as people don't fear God watching us we
are going to need big brother to watch
us is this something I've said
always as an addendum to the John Adams
quote about the moral and religious
people which is
there will be order
there there must be order and peace in
society that is that is what government
does is it to maintain that is what
political communities are largely for
if people will not order their own lives
someone is going to come in and order
our lives for us but there will don't
mistake it
the the people that control the country
the powers that be will not allow things
to spiral out of control even when those
powers are we the people even when it's
us in representative assemblies if our
government really were still to work as
the bill up on Capitol Hill and all the
rest of it
we would not allow anarchism you're
seeing this in some of the blue cities
where crime has gotten completely out of
control people are stepping up they're
saying we don't want this stuff anymore
okay impose some
control right now head on over to
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show it
is extremely important to protect your
online privacy with a VPN choosing a VPN
that you trust is just as important the
only VPN that I trust is expressvpn
these guys have been with the show
Almost since the very beginning I think
it's so easy I'm basically a Luddite
it's super easy to just you just
download the apps right there on your
computer on your phone on your tablet
whatever you want click one button you
are protected expressvpn does not log
your online activity they've even
developed a trusted server technology
that makes it impossible for their
servers to store any data at all number
two the speed expressvpn does not slow
down your user experience you can even
stream HD videos with zero buffering
number three expressvpn is super easy to
use you just click those buttons and and
you're good you're protected it's not
just me saying this Business Insider The
Verge many other Tech journals rate
expressvpn the number one VPN in the
world protect yourself with a VPN I
trust your use my link expressvpn.com
michaelenoll's show today get three
months free on a one year package that's
expresvpn.com Michael Knowles show
expressvpn.com slash Michael Knowles
show
now speaking of big brother in The Nanny
State it's a story that seems a little
bit murky and the government is trying
to kind of deny this the consumer
product safety Commission
has threatened to take away your gas
stove
of all the problems facing the country
completely open border potential World
War breaking out in Eastern Europe
you've got a biggest drug epidemic ever
in American history declining life
expectancy all of these problems the
government
is really focused on what matters which
is keeping you from from using a gas
stove to make your eggs in the morning
yeah you've got to use an electric stove
now that was the threat
from the consumer product safety
Commission
this came out people pushed back against
it even some Democrats came out Joe
manchin was interviewed about this he
said this is insane nobody wants to stop
trying to ban gas stoves you weirdos
that's fine so
then the government came and said no
we're not actually threatening to to
ban the gas stoves here is the consumer
product safety commissioner threatening
this just back in December I think we
need to be talking about regulating gas
stoves whether that's drastically
improving emissions or Banning gas
stoves entirely and I think we ought to
keep that possibility of a band in mind
as as you follow along
because it's a powerful tool in our
toolbox and it's a real possibility here
no thanks no thank you how did this guy
one if you if you cook at all you know
gas stoves are just much nicer to cook
on if you have the privilege of having a
gas stove I've had electric and I've had
gas at different gas is way way better
but how did this guy muster the gumption
to say uh yeah we're getting we're
taking your stove away yeah why because
I said so because I some petty
bureaucrat said so because we
have a culture now
where we have infantilized ourselves and
we've given up so much of our right and
our spines and in some cases other body
parts thanks to the transgender Movement
we we've given this away we no longer
have a clear vision of virtue and our
rights and our place in society we can't
even defend many people in this country
can't even defend the most basic right
in the society
and as we give those things away
then the people who are going to impose
the order that we previously would have
fearing God are going to be Petty
bureaucrats like the guy who's trying to
take your stove
[Music]
[Music]